Okay, this lecture
is called Pigmented
Lesions, and I'm going
to be discussing nevi.
Nevi are basically
moles or beauty marks.
I'll be discussing benign
growth of the skin,
hemangiomas, which are
a collection of blood
vessels under the
skin, and skin cancers.
So I have several cases
for us to review. The first
case, this is a healthy
eight-year-old female who
presents for evaluation of
what you see here is this
dome-shaped papule. It's
kind of like a red-brown
papule, and it's on the
face. But the clue here is
that it has grown rapidly
in the past four months.
It's asymptomatic. It
has not bled, but the
patient's concerned
because it's grown rapidly.
so what's your differential
diagnosis we are going
to be going over all of
these type of moles spitz
nevus halo nevus blue
nevus and nevus spilus so
that you're better able
to make a differential
diagnosis and kind of know
what this lesion is and you
may have to biopsy it that
that That is true, but
it'll kind of lead you
to a better differential.
So this is called a
spitz nevus, and a
spitz nevus is a
dome-shaped, smooth,
hairless papule. It's
most often pink. It could
be very other colors,
such as tan and brown,
sometimes black, but the
clue here is that it has
recent rapid growth.
The most common location
is on the head and neck,
and it's most common in
children. It's rarely
seen over the age of 40.
And what we do is we
can do a biopsy. If
this patient's concerned
because it's rapidly
growing, we would, of
course, do a biopsy.
Spitz nevi are benign, but
if the pathologist looks
under the microscope after
we do a biopsy, there
can be histologic similarity
to melanoma. And actually,
years ago, these were
called juvenile melanoma.
Next is a halo nevus.
Now, sometimes a patient
just has this nevus, and
there's no halo around it.
And then all of a sudden,
they develop a halo around it.
So a halo nevus is a
development of a halo
around a pre-existing
nevus. And sometimes
the halo may be preceded
by some redness.
And then what can
happen with this is
that the nevus can
actually, this nevus
over here, can
actually disappear.
And the halo around
it can repigment
back to the patient's
normal skin.
And the only reason
to biopsy this is if
the nevus was
suspicious or irregular.
The halo around it
is not the suspicious
part of it, okay?
So the lesions can
undergo spontaneous
involution, often with
regression of the
centrally located nevus.
so this if you see this
picture it's very well defined
bluish type of papule on
the scalp this is called
a blue nevis and this is
benign it can be dark blue
to gray or black it's
commonly found on the hands
buttocks back scalp or face
and it has it's very very
well defined it does not
have any irregular color
its border is well defined
so no irregular border
here we have a nevus spilus
this is a light brown
pigmented patch they're
usually pretty large greater
than 15 centimeters is pretty
large but what's a clue
here is it has these little
tiny dark brown small
papules right here right
here all these are dark brown
small papules okay and
they're scattered throughout
the pigmented background
so this is a benign lesion
the next case this patient
has discrete stuck on
greasy warty papules of the
skin and actually patients
say that they're so stuck
on that you can actually
pick them off. And that's
what sometimes they do.
They actually pick them
off. And there's no problem
with that. It's just that
they'll grow back again.
So this is a suburea keratosis.
It's the most common type of
benign tumor, and it's genetic.
Also, elderly patients
are more susceptible to
this. So patients come
in. They don't like what
they look like. They
said, all of a sudden, I
got a lot of these.
Well, I tell them, blame
your mother or your father
because it's genetic.
And as you get older, you
can get more of these.
And they don't like it
for cosmetic reasons.
So patient states that
all of these lesions
appeared abruptly
over the past month.
What is this called and
why are you concerned?
So it's normal for suburea
keratosis to develop.
over time, especially
if you're genetically
predisposed, right? But what
happens if a patient comes
in and all of a sudden
they get a whole bunch
of these over a very,
very short period of time?
This is called the
sign of Lesser Trelat,
and this can be the
sign of internal
malignancy, most
common GI malignancy.
So here you have something
called dermatosis papulosa
*****. This is suburea
keratosis that are more,
they're darker, they're
dark brown to black.
They're seen more in pigmented
patients, but they're
mostly a lot tinier than
the suburea keratosis.
This next case, so what do
you see here? You see this
dermal nodule, erythematous
dermal nodule on the skin.
And then if you take your
thumb and your index finger
on either side, your thumb
here and your index finger
here, and you kind of press
on it, you'll see a sign
called the dimple sign.
And that's a sign that this
is a dermal fibroma. And
why does this happen? Well,
it's very common from trauma.
I tell patients it happens
after shaving. It can happen
after an infected hair
follicle. So you get this
slightly erythematous to
hyperpigmented dermal nodule
on the leg after shaving
or a hair follicle or some
kind of trauma. So here you
see a picture of the two
fingers pushing this lesion
together and it's causing
a dimple sign. And this is
called the dimple sign. So
it's a lateral compression
with the thumb and index
finger causing a depression.
so domatofibroma is a fibrous
reaction to trauma or a
bite it occurs most commonly
on the legs and it's
only important because of its
cosmetic appearance patients
don't like it but it can
be mistaken for melanoma
when it's pigmented so you
always have to watch out
for that it's usually
asymptomatic but it's more of a
cosmetic nuisance the
patients don't like it I never
recommend it being removed
because it's really deeper
under the skin and if we
excise it they're going to
have a different kind of
scar they're gonna you know
we have to put stitches in
so I really never recommend
that these be removed and
then you have the dimple
sign which is the depression
or dimple of the lesion.
The next case this is a
female a 64 year old female
presents with these flesh
-colored pedunculated papules
on the neck we already
went over this these are
called skin tags it's very
common in areas that have
friction sun exposed not sun
exposed I'm sorry friction
or opposing areas of the
skin such as under the
armpits under the breast and
the neck and it's a nuisance
to this patient because
it becomes irritated when
she wears a necklace so
that's why we remove these
it's more common in the
elderly it's more common in
obese patients genetics
absolutely pays plays a
part patients can be more
susceptible to these just
because you're older just
because you're obese doesn't
necessarily mean that
you're the only ones who
get these genetics actually
you know play a big part
in it they can be skin
colored pedunculated papules
but they can also would
be other colors, such as
tan or brown, and they're
more common in, as I
mentioned, the intertriginous
areas, the neck, eyelids,
axilla, breasts.
And I showed you how to
treat them before. We just
inject a little numbing
medicine, and we snip them off.
Next case, this is a 24
-year-old construction
worker, presents with
this lesion that quickly
develops after he injured
his finger at work.
Now, this is a ******,
papual patient injured
himself and then developed
this, what's called
a pyogenic granuloma.
It bleeds frequently.
Pyogenic granuloma is
a rapidly developing
hemangioma arising at
sites of minor trauma.
It's a nodule that bleeds
spontaneously, and you
could see that it could
bleed very easily. And
it's very common around
the fingers, lips, toes,
and we want to excise
this because we just don't
want it to spontaneously
bleed all the time, but
you have to differentiate
this from a melanoma.
So here you see
pyogenic granuloma.
What else is in your
differential diagnosis
for this lesion on
the face of a child?
so here you see that this
patient has this nodule on
the face and it looks a
little ****** but patient says
I've had this for years and
years and years and there
was no trauma here and it's
kind of grown rapidly in
the past few months you always
have to make worry about
a spitz nevus the next case
this is a 50 year old male,
presents with flesh to
yellow colored papules on the
cheeks. They have donut
shaped appearances. They are
not painful, but they affect
him cosmetically. Here you
see this kind of pink to
yellow donut shaped papule.
Donut shaped papule.
You have a center
that's like a
donut here as well.
And these are called sebaceous
hyperplasia. And these
are tumors of enlarged
sebaceous glands where in
the center you get some
umbilication so you see
that center there's a hole
there looks like a donut
they can be pale and yellow
and it's very common on
the face the forehead the
cheeks the lids the nose
but you have to differentiate
these from seringomas
seringomas are usually more
commonly on their lower
lids but what do you see
here these kind of yellow
to flesh-colored papules
on the lower lids these
are sweat duct tumors flesh
color papules lower lids
and they can occur elsewhere
but this is the most
common area so you want
to differentiate this from
the sebaceous hyperplasia
which is donut shaped you
want to differentiate this
from trichoepithelioma
so what do you see
here you see these
kind of shiny
pearly pink papules
many of them on the
face. These are benign
appendageal tumors
called trichoepithelioma,
and they're pink to
skin color papules. But
the reason why I
mentioned this pearliness
is because they can
resemble basal cell
carcinoma, which also
has a pearly appearance.
And then you have milium.
This is amelia. What
amelia is, is basically a
small little cyst that has
keratin in it it's that
cheesy material that comes
out of a cyst and they're
very very small so it's
superficial white to yellow
keratin containing cyst
located on the face the
eyelids the cheeks even
sites of trauma or even if
you're using a very heavy
moisturizer heavy
moisturizers that clog your
pores you can get this milia
and what do we do to get
rid of them. We just make
a little incision here
and express it, and you
get that cheesy material.
Next case, it's a baby
presenting with a red
strawberry-appearing plaque
on her trunk. The parents
are concerned because it's
rapidly growing, and the
dermatologist tells them
not to worry because the
lesion may disappear
before she's 10 years old.
This is a strawberry nevus.
Now, a strawberry nevus
is a benign vascular tumor
or vascular proliferation,
and it enlarges rapidly
by the first year, but
then it can certainly
resolve or involute by
the age of five and then
definitely, or most
likely by the age of 10. I
wouldn't say definitely.
There are some that can
continue, but most of them
resolve by the age of 10.
So this is a vascular
proliferation.
Now, this is a vascular
malformation called the
cavernous hemangioma. And
this is a deep vascular
malformation. It's composed
of capillaries, lymphatics,
and venous tissue. But the
thing about this, it's not
hard. It's very soft and
very compressible. So you
can actually push in and
you'll see how compressible
it is. And these also can
resolve by the age of 10.
now a portline stain is a
vascular malformation that
does not undergo spontaneous
involution so this is
pretty much permanent except
if you want to do laser
treatments laser treatments
can really help this and this
is an irregular shaped patch
that's present at birth
it does not cross the
midline in many cases but if
it does cross the midline
then you have variants that
are associated with it that
can affect the eye and the
brain. So usually when it's
like this, it's unilateral,
it doesn't even go up
to the eye, it's usually
confined to the skin. But in
some cases when it goes above
the eye and it crosses
the midline, it can affect
the eye and the brain and
this is a variant called
Sturge-Weber syndrome, which
is a port wine stain with
also a vascular malformation
of the eye and the brain.
And then you have Krippel
-Trenanay syndrome,
which is a port wine
stain with ***********
of the extremity. So
you have this port wine
stain on the leg, and
then you see how swollen
this is. And look here,
how swollen this is.
Okay, this is
very, very common.
These are called
cherry angiomas.
And what they are
are the little
blood vessels under the skin.
Sorry, I just had
to drink some water.
there are blood vessels
under the skin and they're
bright dome-shaped papules
they're principally on the
trunk and they occur in
the first like they occur
just like skin tags it's
genetic they increase with
age they you have the genetic
predisposition to getting
them but they're but
they're cosmetic okay moving
on to case eight so what
do you see here you see
these erythematous crusted
papules on this patient
and they're in sun exposed
area and they shouldn't be
there but this is a 67 year
old male he presents with
these crusted lesions on
his forehead and scalp
and he describes continually
picking at them but they
keep on coming back and of
course they keep on coming
back because he's picking
them but bottom line is
that they're pre-cancerous
lesions so they're going
to come back if you don't
treat them appropriately
so this is actinic keratosis
these are common sun sun
induced pre-malignant
lesions and they usually have
a rough scaly area adherent
on their skin they usually
they could be single or
multiple and they occur in
areas of dermatoheliosis
dermatoheliosis is areas of
sun damaged skin such as
the head neck and hands i
see this on patients ears
patients especially men their
scalp if they're not
wearing a hat um i tell them
to make sure they wear
their hat and they say oh i
don't go in the sun anymore
it's not that you don't go
in the sun now it's when
you were 20 years old and
baked in the sun years ago
and it's a cumulative effect
that causes this. So this
has premalignant potential
and patients from these
lesions may develop into a
squamous cell carcinoma,
which is a skin cancer. So
these lesions, even though
they're premalignant now,
they can turn into skin
cancer. How do we treat this?
Cryotherapy,
which is liquid nitrogen.
We spray liquid nitrogen
on these areas. It blisters
and scabs and gets rid
of the precancerous
lesion. The other thing
that we do is we can use
topical 5-fluorouracil, which
is a topical chemotherapy
medication, and the
chemotherapy destroys
the precancerous cells,
causes an inflammatory
reaction, and gets rid of
the precancerous lesion.
So case nine,
this is, and I'm
going to describe this
because the next several
patients have this.
Here you see an erythematous
papule, a pearly
papule with telangiectasias,
as you see here,
and this is a 61-year-old
fisherman with this lesion.
It was present for a year,
and it's very slow growing,
and this lesion can be
very, very slow growing.
Here you see here a pearly
papule with telangiectasias
with a rolled border.
See that edge is kind
of rolled. And this is a
46-year-old runner with
a slowly growing lesion
on her nose for a year.
And here you have a patch
that looks like a patch of
eczema or psoriasis. A scaly
papule, it's been there.
This is a 44-year-old
female. She reports frequent
tanning habits and had this
lesion for unknown duration.
Maybe it looks like a patch
of eczema or a patch of
psoriasis. You might treat
them with a cortisone cream,
but it doesn't get better
and it keeps on returning.
This is a, all of these,
all three of these cases,
basal cell carcinoma.
It's the most common type
of skin cancer. Now,
even though it's rare to
metastasize, it's locally
invasive and locally
aggressive, which means
that patient that had on the
nose, it can go deeper
and deeper and deeper
under that area. So you
definitely want to take
care of this. It usually
occurs as you get older.
Again, patients say, oh,
I don't go in the sun now,
but it's not from now. It's
from when you were 20 years
old and baked in the sun,
and it's a cumulative effect
over all those years. And
there are seven types.
There's the superficial type,
which looks like a patch
of eczema or psoriasis.
There's the nodula type, which
is the pearly rolled
border papule. It could be
pigmented or dark colored.
It could look like an ulcer.
It can look sclerosing or
scar-like. It can look like
a cyst. And then there's
the basal squamous type.
Basal cell carcinoma
is very common on the
sudden exposed areas,
the head, the scalp,
the nose, the ears.
So let's name that basal cell.
So here you have an
erythematous pearly papule,
kind of has a rolled border,
telangiectasias.
Which one is this?
This is the nodular type.
It's a pearly papular
nodule with telangiectasia
and rolled border.
So here you have a
pearly papule, a little
bit of a rolled
border, and it's
pigmented, right? Which
basal cell is this?
This is the
pigmented basal cell.
Here you have what looks like
patches of eczema, psoriasis,
right? So it almost
looks like a rash, a
dermatitis. So which
basal cell is this?
This is the superficial
type. And the only way to
determine which type these
are is by doing a biopsy.
so here you have a patient
that has this ulcer right
near the eye and it the
patient has like a scar
-like lesion over here and
then has several nodules
over here so this is a large
scar-like lesion containing
several small nodules
of basal cells and then
here you have this ulcer
representing the rodent ulcer
which is indicative of
the ulcerating basal cell.
This is the sclerosing
type looks like a scar and
this has the worst prognosis
because even if you
treat these kind of don't
see where the borders are so
that's why they say this
has the worst prognosis.
And here it looks like
a patch of psoriasis
or eczema this is the
superficial type red
scaly plaque, pearly
white border, and this
is the least aggressive
of the basal cells.
How do you manage these?
Well, you can excise
them. That's one way.
We do what's called a
DNC, where we numb the
patient, we use a curette,
we scrape the basal
cell out, and we kind of
burn the surface of it
a little bit deeper,
and we curette it, and
we do that three times.
You can use cryotherapy
or liquid nitrogen.
There's Mohs surgery.
Mohs surgery is where
you take the lesion.
The surgeon takes the lesion.
You process it in the lab.
You basically look under
the, you put it on a slide.
You look under the
microscope. You see if there's
any more skin cancer on the
patient or any more skin
cancer outside the borders
of the lesion. And then
you go back to the patient
and you take another
piece. And you go back and
forth until it's all gone.
Topical immunomodulators,
such as a miquimod,
that is treatment for
basal cell. And that's more
or less for the superficial
types of basal cell.
And then we have
radiation treatment.
So here's an example
of the DNC. You
have this curette,
and you're just
basically scraping
out the basal cell.
And this is Mohs surgery.
This is the basal
cell here, but it also
extends out to here.
You can see a little bit
of the pink areas. So
this is before Mohs.
And remember I said,
you take pieces of skin,
you look under the
microscope to see if there's
any more skin cancer,
and you could go back and
forth until the skin cancer
is all gone. And this is
after Mohs. So this is
how deep this lesion was.
so the next case this is
almost like looks like a
patch of eczema it's an
erythematous scaly patch so
describe this lesion on the
upper back of a 54 year old
female the lesion has been
there for four months and
so you think it's a patch
of eczema psoriasis what do
you do you treat it with a
topical steroid. However,
the patient did not respond
to the topical steroid.
So this is a squamous
cell carcinoma
in situ. This
means superficial.
Another name for this is
Bowen's disease. So this
is a scaly plaque, pink
to red scaly plaque, and
SCCIS, the abbreviation
for squamous cell carcinoma
in situ. It's most often
caused by the sun or
it can also be caused
by human papillomavirus
infection. And it commonly
arises out of those actinic
keratosis that we just
saw. So you can have an
actinic keratosis. If it's
not treated appropriately,
it can turn into a
squamous cell carcinoma.
And SCCIS can also come out
of an HPV-induced lesion.
Similar but unusually,
usually non-scaly lesions
on the glands and *****
are called erythroplasia.
And anogenital HPV-induced
SCCIS is referred to as
boanoid papulosis. Now,
untreated SCCIS can
eventually, so it's superficial
now, but it can eventually
progress to invasive
squamous cell carcinoma.
How do you treat
this SCCIS? Well,
because it's superficial,
you can actually
treat it with
topical medication.
5-fluorouracil, this is
a topical chemotherapy
treatment. immune
modulators such as imiquimod
is also used to treat
SCCIS. Laser treatments,
most surgery can also treat it.
So describe these lesions
for the next condition.
This is called not squamous
cell carcinoma in situ,
but squamous cell carcinoma.
So it's more invasive.
You see how thick it is it
doesn't look like a plaque
of eczema or psoriasis it
looks a little more like
a little wart or a little
warty plaque and it's
hyperkeratotic it's thickened
look at this looks like a
little wart right so this
is invasive squamous cell
carcinoma this is malignant
tumor of the keratinocytes
and it usually arises out
of precancerous lesions
such as the actinic keratosis.
It can also arise out
of SCCIS and it varies in
its aggressiveness. Well,
it varies in its aggressiveness
depending on what
caused it. Was it sun
induced? Was it HPV induced?
And its level of differentiation,
what stage it's in.
So these are hyperkeratotic
in sun exposed areas,
such as the face, the
ears, the scalp, the hands,
the lower lips, in basically
very similar areas that
basal cell carcinomas
are more frequently found
in. And the treatment is
very similar, the same kind
of thing that you can do
with DNC, most surgery.
And the majority of
sun-induced lesions
have a low rate of
distant metastasis.
But that's in
healthy individuals.
More aggressive
SECs can occur in
immunosuppressed or
immunocompromised patients.
This is the next case.
This is a 55-year-old male.
He has this lesion on his
back. His wife wants you to
biopsy it. But he says
the lesion's been present
since birth, right? He doesn't
believe it's changed in
any way, shape, or form.
So do you biopsy it or not?
Do you recommend the
biopsy? Yes or no?
Look at this. It's very
well defined, right?
The pigmentation is
very, very uniform.
No, you don't biopsy it. What
do you call this
type of lesion?
It's a congenital nevus
or congenital mole. And
it's present since birth.
It's highly pigmented.
You can actually get
hair growing out of it.
And the small and medium
ones don't really have an
increased risk of
developing melanoma, it's
equal to the general
population. However, the larger
ones, the giant nevi,
the ones greater than 20
centimeters, they do
have a risk of developing
melanoma. But the removal is
very, very, very difficult.
40% of melanomas in kids do
develop within these nevi.
Okay, here's the
next case. What do
you do next? Here
you have a patient.
She has a little lesion here.
What happens 11 months
later? Look at this lesion,
how big it got, right?
So what do you do next?
You look at the
ABCDEs of melanoma.
That's what you do.
You want to see if that
lesion has any of the
ABCDEs of melanoma.
So the first thing you
look at is asymmetry.
You cut this in half.
is it symmetrical or
asymmetrical it's asymmetrical
you have this on this
side and this on this side
it does not look the same
correct the next is border
irregularity look at
this border how irregular
this border is right so
that's a sign of melanoma
look at the color
variation look at this is
black this is light brown.
So the color is, there's
differences in
the color, right?
Here you have diameter
greater than six
millimeters. If you measure
this, it's greater than
six millimeters. That's
a sign of melanoma.
And the last one is
evolving. You see here, and
you see evolving into
this. So this is a sign of
melanoma. So what are the
risk factors of melanoma?
Moles, especially
irregular ones,
greater than five on a patient.
Common moles greater
than 50 on a patient.
Red hair and freckling.
Inability to tan, right? So
if you're very light, fair
-skinned, you have an increased
risk. Severe sunburn,
any kind of sunburn,
but especially under
the age of 14 with
a severe sunburn,
and family history.
So this is your
malignant melanoma
risk, a mnemonic.
This case, this is a 63
-year-old female, shows you a
dark area under her toenail.
Now she thinks she stubbed
her nail a few months
prior while working in the
garden, so she thinks that
this is just from trauma
but look at the nail it
extends from here all the ways
to here and there's some
pigment where the nail bed
is right so what's the
sign where you have pigment
beyond the nail bed this is
called the Hutchinson sign
and these are longitudinal
pigmented streaks that
extend from the proximal
or lateral nail fold out.
So this could be a
sign of melanoma.
Acral antigenous melanoma,
70% of these melanomas
occur in African-American
patients, and they're
located on the acral areas
of the body, such as the
palms, the soles, the
nail beds, the mucous
membranes, and they have
a very poor prognosis.
They tend to metastasize
early. So you really want
to make this diagnosis
And that concludes
this lecture.